MALE SPEAKER: So next up
we have Mr. Jake Archibald,
who you met before.
Jake is a long time
front end developer.
He originally worked on the
Glow library at the BBC.
It was kind of like a competitor
to jQuery sort of back
then because they
needed IE 5.5 support.
Is that the reason?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And 5.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and 5.
IE 5 support.
Yeah, this was good.
He also is an expert
in @font-face.
He made a fantastic
offline tool for creating
CSS sprites called Sprite Cow.
He developed a technique for
including IE specific styles
with Sass IE, naturally.
More recently, you might
know him from his work
with the Application
Cache, where
he wrote a number of
articles and talks.
And today, he's going to be
telling you a little bit more
about ServiceWorker.
So, Jake Archibald.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hey.
[APPLAUSE]
So I couldn't help notice that
in Mat's list of talks there
that you should pay attention
to, mine wasn't on there.
So no Christmas card
for you this year.
So making stuff work offline
used to be very easy, right?
I mean, it's only
really become an issue
since the advent
of the internet.
Before that, you had everything
you needed in front of you.
You had the machine
that was going
to do 100% of the
processing, and you
had the thing that was
going to be processed.
This is the first
computer I ever owned.
And we should have audio here.
Oh, we do a little bit.
[BEEPING]
And these were the
sights and sounds
you would get just
to do something
like render a simple
image on the page.
And I got this working on a
Spectrum emulator last week,
and it's the most
fun I've had in ages.
And I uploaded it to
YouTube, the full video.
And someone actually
took the audio,
recorded it onto a
cassette, and played it
in a real ZX Spectrum.
And it worked.
Well, it crashed
at the very end.
But for me, that makes
it more authentic.
It was great.
But in these days--
the only thing
you needed from outside the
building was electricity.
And that came from beyond the
wall, wherever it comes from.
As long as that stream was
constant, then you were gold.
Everything would work.
But then we got another stream.
We got another stream
from beyond the wall,
the internet, data on demand.
It looks like people were
terrified of it at first.
But not anymore.
In fact, now, even things
that are kind of built
around physical media, they
can't resist a delicious slurp
of internet before
they'll do anything.
I don't-- I didn't buy
new games for the PS3.
Because you would go through
this every couple of months
where every time you would
try and play the game,
it wanted to connect
to the internet
and download a 50
megabyte update.
And I just wanted
to play a game.
And they do automatic
updates now.
It's about time, really.
Yeah, I just want
to play the game.
I've got the disk
here in my hand.
These days, most
devices will ship
with a cache for
electricity which
can be used when the
stream isn't available.
And we call it a battery.
In fact, as we've become less
reliant on this electricity
stream, we've become more
reliant on the internet stream,
especially on the web.
I became very aware
of this back when
I worked at a small agency.
You see, one day I needed
to go to the toilet.
And there were five cubicles
for me to choose from.
But unfortunately,
on this instance,
the first four were occupied.
And that's usually OK.
I tend to only need
one toilet per visit.
But I knew from
previous experience
that the office Wi-Fi only
extended to the first four.
And there's no mobile
data in there either.
And I thought for a moment.
And I was like, no.
No, I don't consider
this good enough anymore.
As a human being,
it's my right to have
internet when I
go to the toilet.
I've been using this
joke for a while now.
But it comes with
an important update.
In the Google offices--
or certainly in the UK--
the situation is much worse.
We have no data
at all, completely
data-less to the point where
saying, I'm just going offline,
has become a kind of euphemism.
Of course, there
are other places
without internet, like large
parts of my daily commute
because I get the train in
through the countryside,
underground systems of course,
planes, international roaming.
You have data, but it's
too expensive to use.
Have we lost something
through this data dependency?
Wouldn't it be great if things
like Wikipedia or Google
Maps and YouTube were once
again resilient to fluctuations
in connectivity?
Well, as a community,
we thought so.
And we asked for a solution.
And thus, we received
the Application Cache.
How did that turn out?
I have voiced my opinions
on AppCache before.
But today, I would like to
defer to the philosopher Andre
the Giant from then
WWF, who said this.
I don't like to speak
badly of people.
I have grown up thinking and
being told that if you cannot
say something nice
about someone,
you should not say
anything at all.
Yeah.
Oh, but I must break
that rule in this case
because I hate Hulk
Hogan very much.
He is a big ugly goon, and
I want to squash his face.
Yeah.
AppCache needs
squashed in the face.
The problem with AppCache
is it's like this.
It looks so simple, so inviting,
so easy to get started.
But it comes with an instruction
manual, and it's huge.
And if you don't read it
all and remember it all,
you will be caught out.
If I make an HTML
page, and point it
at a manifest like this
and list some files in it,
and it'll be cached and it'll
work offline, and that's great.
But any page that points at
the manifest, just index HTML5
here-- that will automatically
become part of the cache.
And that counts per URL.
So if the URL just has a
change in the query string,
that's a new thing that will
be automatically cached.
And this will just
build up and up and up.
There's no way you
can prevent it,
and there's nothing you
can do to clear it out
once it happens.
Also, on a page like this,
the CSS is going to work.
That should be-- it
shouldn't be SCS, should it?
What am I doing?
Anyway, the
JavaScript will work.
But what about this?
This won't load even
if you're online,
because it's not in the cache.
And AppCache won't let network
requests through by default,
unless you add this little
bit of magic at the bottom.
Of course, this is
all in the manual.
But there's nothing
in the manifest there
that hints to me that
this is the behavior,
this is what I should expect.
I was on a transatlantic flight,
and I had nothing better to do.
I was offline.
So I tried to draw
how AppCache works.
And it took me like
eight hours, partly
because the specification
is so dense,
and it kept confounding
my expectations.
But also because the person
in front had fully reclined,
so I was having to use
my laptop like a T Rex.
But it's that complicated.
And there's nothing wrong
with high level APIs, right?
I mean, look at jQuery.
They looked at what people
were doing with the DOM, all
the common stuff, and
they made shortcuts.
Some quite overloaded methods.
You need to know what the
different arguments actually
do.
But it works in practice.
They're really nice shortcuts.
However, AppCache tried
to be the shortcut
before it knew the long cuts.
It looked really sweet on paper.
But when developers
actually look closely at it,
we go like, ugh, no, don't
like the look of that.
Take that away.
So we're going to
give it another try.
We're giving it another try.
And the new thing is
the ServiceWorker.
Actually, I think this
is the first talk on it.
So that didn't feel like
a deserving introduction.
So we'll give that another go.
And the new thing is
the ServiceWorker.
But yeah.
The current status is
it's a specification
that we're developing,
drafting on GitHub.
We've been working on this
a while, along with Mozilla
and other third parties
who are interested.
We've been prototyping bits
and pieces in the browser.
But the spec is still
a work in progress.
I'm going to show
you bits of it.
And any feedback you
have on it, anything
you see you don't like,
you can talk to me.
You can ask me in the
Q&A. But you can also
file issues on GitHub.
There's nothing to play
with in the browser yet,
but we're hoping to hit canary
sometime early next year.
So what is the ServiceWorker?
Well, it's a
JavaScript context that
operates for a set of URLs.
And you can use it
to manage behavior.
It's actually kind of easier
to show you rather than
describe it.
So on just a normal page, you
would register a ServiceWorker
like this.
The first argument,
you're telling
it which URLs you want
it to be in charge of.
The second argument, the
URL to the JavaScript file
that's going to do
all the controlling.
And congratulations, you
now have a ServiceWorker.
And the ServiceWorker is very
similar to a shared worker.
I mean, it exists
separately to the pages.
And multiple pages
can communicate
with the same instance
of the ServiceWorker.
If you've developed
Chrome apps before,
this is kind of similar to
the background pages model.
But these are much lighter.
They don't have a document.
They've got no DOM.
They're less of a memory
burden and less startup cost
than a whole page would be.
So our ServiceWorker file
currently looks like this.
It's empty.
And how does that affect
the behavior of pages?
Well, it doesn't.
Magic was a huge
problem with AppCache.
An empty AppCache file
would start doing things.
This doesn't.
ServiceWorker aims to have
as little magic as possible.
It's a bring your own magic API.
You can make your
own magic with it.
But by default, it doesn't
do anything you don't expect.
You're in full control.
But what control do
you actually get?
Well, you can listen
in on network requests.
You get this event.
Some just like listening to the
event using the old DOM method,
but you can use add event
listener if you want as well.
So here, if I navigate to
slash whatever slash fubar,
I'm going to get a
console lock for that
in this other JavaScript file.
But I also get one
for any request
that I triggered by
that page as well,
even they're to another domain.
The usual cross
origin rules apply
when it comes to accessing data.
But you'll still get the
event for the request actually
happening.
Anyway, so what?
Well, like other events
we have in the browser,
you can prevent the default.
And you can do something else.
So here, I'm looking
at the request URL,
and I'm looking
to see if it ends
with one of the
image extensions.
And then I'm going to
call event.respondwith.
And event.respondwith
takes a response object,
which is new in ServiceWorker.
Or it will take a promise,
which will eventually
resolve to a response.
And the fetch method, which
is also new in ServiceWorker,
is going to give you a promise
for a response to the URL you
give it.
So here I'm just redirecting
all of the requests or--
and they're going to serve up
this not-a-cat image instead
of any other images on the page.
So note here I'm actually
satisfying a cross origin
request with a same
origin response.
And you can do the
opposite as well.
Security is always determined by
the origin of the response, not
the request.
This isn't an HTTP redirect.
You're just serving
up a different file.
As far as the
browser's concerned,
it requested
probably-cats-again,
and it got it.
But you could do an HTTP
redirect if you want.
In fact, you can create
any kind of response.
We have a kind of low
level API for that.
So new same origin response,
give it a content type.
Give it a body.
And I'm going to serve that up.
And you can see
how you could start
to make things work
offline with this.
Like, I get a template
from the file system API.
I can get some data
from index database
and mush them together
and serve that out.
But that would be a
lot of code, and it
would involve some
pretty gnarly APIs.
So we're introducing a new
storage system specifically
for this, and it's
the cache list.
So we just need to
unfetch, but there
are other events
as well on install.
So this is called
when the browser sees
the ServiceWorker
for the first time.
It's your opportunity
to get everything ready
before you start
hearing about requests,
handling requests.
So in here, I can create a new
cache, give it a set of URLs,
and add it onto
the caches object.
And these are just URLs.
They can be from another domain.
That's fine.
And they'll be downloaded,
and we add them
to this cache called
static-v1 or whatever.
Now the cache won't
serve responses
until all of those files
have successfully downloaded.
And if one of them
fails, then you
get nothing for
that whole cache.
This is a good way to
group files together
that are dependent
on each other.
So if you can get the
network-failed.html out
of the cache, you
know the PNG is there.
The JS is there.
The CSS is definitely there.
They're dependent on each other.
We're creating one
cache here, but you
could create many,
like for a game.
You could create a cache
per level, for instance.
For a newspaper, you
could do a cache per issue
or a cache per article.
And then we wait on the cache.
So event.waitUntil
takes a promise.
And this is where you can
say, look, I'm not actually
ready to handle requests
until this stuff has happened.
On cache objects, you
get this ready method,
which will resolve once that
cache has successfully formed.
You might wait on
all of your caches,
or you might only wait on some.
So in the game model, you
might only wait on level one
and allow the other levels to
download in the background.
And you'll just handle it
if level two is not there
for whatever reason.
For instance, if the
user goes offline
while that's still downloading
levels two and three,
you can still offer an offline
experience for level one.
And then when the user gets
to the end of level one,
you can say, look, we don't
have the files for level two.
We've saved your position,
and when you're next online,
we can pick up
where we left off.
But we're just
creating caches here.
We're not actually using them.
To use them, we go back
to our own fetch method.
And once again, the
respondWith method,
and I'm just going
to ask the caches
for a match for this URL.
I can be specific
and say, look, I only
want to get a match
from the cache named
static-v1 or whatever.
But we don't really
need to do that here.
We don't need to
be that specific.
Of course, if that doesn't
match anything in our caches--
because we're handling all
requests at the moment- we're
going to get a hard failure,
even if the user's online
because we're saying, go to
the cache for everything.
But this whole thing
is promise based,
promises that we now have
in a DOM in JavaScript.
So we can fix that just by
adding .catch to the end and do
something else.
If you're unfamiliar
with how promises work,
then there is an HTML5
Rocks article coming.
It should be out next month.
That hopefully will explain it.
But all sync success
failure methods
in JavaScript in the DOM
are moving to this model.
So if you fail to get stuff from
the cache for whatever reason,
like something
fails or there's not
something in the
cache for that URL,
we fall down to this next step.
And what I'm doing
is I'm using fetch.
And I'm just going to
pipe through the requests.
So we're going to
go to the network.
Of course, if there's
nothing in the cache,
and the network request fails,
we're going to get nothing.
But we can fix that as well.
We can catch again.
And here, I'm going to
go to the cache again,
and I'm going to get the
network-failed.html file
and serve that.
And I know that's there
because I depended
on it in the uninstall
method, event even.
And our other page is going to
be better than the browser's
default one because
we can say, hey,
I'm afraid that resource
is not available.
But here's a list
of things which are.
Here's the articles that
are available to you.
Here's the levels
which will work.
As I mentioned before,
onfetch doesn't just
fire for full page navigations.
It also fires for assets on
the page, your JavaScript, XHR,
CSS, images, et cetera.
We can differentiate
between the two
using event.type because
it makes sense here.
We don't want to serve up
network-failed.html for an XHR
request.
That doesn't work.
So here, we can just serve it
up for full page navigations.
So this, this bit of
code-- what does this look
like in AppCache?
Ah.
It's a lot simpler.
But it's not actually
simpler, is it?
It's just less characters.
This doesn't tell
me that for any URL,
it should go to the cache
first and then try the network
and then fall back to
network-failed.html.
And this is just
one of the few cases
that AppCache can actually
do without too much issue.
But you don't get
the full separation
of caching and routing.
But you're going to
get the weird auto
caching of all pages,
that link to it.
And if you want it to serve
a different fall back for XHR
compared to navigations,
AppCache can't do that.
If this, the worker code,
starts doing something
I don't understand,
what can I do?
I can add a console.log.
I can add a JavaScript
break point,
and I can step through
it step by step
and look at all the
values of variables,
look at the whole
state on every step.
If this does something I
don't expect-- and it will--
we're back to the manual.
Read the whole thing again.
When I was building Lanyard's
offline enabled mobile site,
I found out some devices
were behaving differently
when they were out of signal to
when they were in flight mode.
And what I was
most interested in
is doing a proper
no reception test.
But how could I test
genuinely no reception?
This is before I
worked at Google,
so I couldn't just pop
along to Faraday's lavatory
and sit there testing phones.
So I populated the
caches on each device,
and I went to the local
underground station
because there's no mobile
reception down there.
And I tested each
devices, see what it did.
And I was filming it
with a digital camera
so I could review it later on.
And I looked up, and I saw
that two police officers were
kind of standing in front of
me, pulling faces and pointing
behind me.
And I look around, and I was
sitting in between two posters.
One said, someone's got
more than one mobile phone.
Probably a terrorist.
Doing something odd with a
camera, probably a terrorist.
I was ticking all
of the terror boxes.
Thankfully, the police
thought this was hilarious
and decided not to
shoot me to pieces,
which was very nice of them.
So the ServiceWorker lets us
build these offline experiences
in a flexible and testable way.
But who cares?
I mean, we've got
train journeys,
plane journey, roaming abroad.
But mobile coverage is just
getting better and better.
Planes and trains are getting
Wi-Fi, some even for free.
And mobile providers
are starting
to remove roaming costs.
Maybe even one day, Google
will put a Wi-Fi antenna
outside the toilets.
Is this problem going away, this
problem of zero connectivity?
When I first started
making stuff work offline,
my instinct was to
build things as normal
and then catch the
users that were offline.
And you can do that
in ServiceWorker
because, do what you want.
I can do onfetch, event,
respondWith, go to the network,
and then catch that
and do something else,
like pull some data
out of the cache.
So people who have
never connectivity
are going to get
fresh data every time.
Users without
connectivity are rescued.
We can give them something.
This is graceful degradation.
And as we found with
graceful degradation,
it's the wrong way around.
You see, when I want to get
something from the internet,
I have to wake up the
radio or the Wi-Fi devices.
Non 3G, that can take
a couple of seconds.
And then we can begin
the epic journey
to get data from somewhere
else in the world.
And it's a dangerous business,
going out onto the internet.
We need to negotiate the router,
ISP, DNS, intermediate proxies,
the destination server,
grab what we need,
and then come back
through all those things.
And it's a lot to do.
And if any of these
things are busy or flaky,
we're going to be slow.
Or worse, we're going to
end up with a total failure.
But we don't know it's going to
be fast or slow until we try.
We don't know it's
going to succeed or fail
until one of those
two things happens.
And this epic journey
is per request,
and your pages are
made out of many.
This is why I like
progressive enhancement,
because you can get stuff
on the screen with less
requirements from the network.
A bit of the HTML and
the CSS comes down,
you can start rendering.
But ultimately, it's
still network dependent.
And when your phone's like this,
it's like a one legged dog.
It thinks it can still
play fetch, but it can't.
And boy, will it try.
And you have to sit there
watching it drag itself
along the floor
with its one leg.
And it's heartbreaking.
It'll spend minutes
trying before it gives up.
But even if your
connection's like this,
you're still at the
mercy of everything
else out on in the internet,
any problems that are there.
And if you've got
something already
on the device, if you already
have an offline experience, why
wait for the network to show it?
You don't have to leave the
device to get to first render.
We should build our
pages offline first.
And the next generation
of progressive enhancement
treats the network as a
potential enhancement,
an enhancement that
might not be available.
So sure, connectivity's
getting better.
But it's very rarely going to
be faster than getting stuff
straight off the device.
This whole thing's as much
about improving performance
for users with
connectivity as it
is for giving something
to those without.
The Hoodie guys
made a great post
about this, which I
recommend reading.
But these ideas are
pretty new to the web.
But some native apps have been
doing this for quite a while.
Here we can compare the loading
of the Google Plus mobile site
versus the native app
over a pretty decent
mobile connection.
Unfortunately, we have
to give the website
a head start in this because
it has a one of these.
I love the web.
I hate this.
We should not be doing this.
But let's-- we'll
gloss over that.
Oh, yeah thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
But let's-- we're going to load
the main site now at the same
time as the app.
So we go.
And the native app has
content on the screen.
There it goes.
And the website's still
thinking about it.
Oh, and now it's being
blocked by a font download.
And eventually,
it comes through.
If we ignore the font
delay, then both the app
and the website actually
got fresh content around
about the same time.
But before that, the native
app shows cache content.
And it feels so much faster.
It looks like it beats the
website by two seconds.
And in this example,
connectivity was good.
And the mobile site
got an advantage
because by going
through the slam door
thing we did a lot of
the DNS work up front.
And we did a lot
of the-- yeah, we
had some [? warmer ?] for
the connections in the radio.
As connectivity
gets worse, the app
is going to look
better and better
compared to the website because
it can just render straight
from the device.
ServiceWorker levels
this playing field.
So we can start by
just serving a page
shell from the
ServiceWorker, just the UI
but no content there.
And we can start up a spinner.
And we can see if we've
got any cached content.
And if we do, we
can show it and then
start going in and fetching
some network content.
If we don't have cached
content, that's fine.
We'll just go to
the network and see
if we can get
something from there.
And once that works, we
can show the new content
and hide the spinner.
If the network
request fails, and we
didn't show any cached
content, then that's a shame.
We have to show
an error message.
But if we did show
cached content,
and the network request fails,
we can actually fail silently.
Because this is just a load
of a page-- the user hasn't
hit the Refresh
button specifically--
this is the offline experience.
And it works.
And this is what a
lot of native apps do.
We can represent that
diagram with promises.
And once again, if promises
make your eyes bleed,
then keep an eye on
HTML5 Rocks next month.
Hopefully, there'll
be an explanation.
But actually, we can do better
than the flow chart because we
can make the network
request at the same time
as we make the cache request.
Because why wait
on the cache before
we actually try
going to the network?
It is possible in extreme cases
that the network request will
beat the cache, like if the
user's hard drive is made
of old cassette tape, but their
internet connection's amazing.
It is possible.
We can let the
two requests race.
But we've got these two methods
where we go and fetch data.
And in one, we're asking
it to go to the cache.
And in the other, we're not.
How does the page
tell the ServiceWorker
were to get the data from?
Well, here's our
implementation of fetch data.
It's just XHR.
It's pretty simple.
If options object dot
useCache is true--
if there's no
ServiceWorker there,
we're just going to
reject at this point
because we can't do
anything about it.
But if the ServiceWorker is
there, we can set header.
We're going to set header x
useCache to be true and then
just serve up the XHR.
I'm kind of pretending
that XHR uses promises,
which it doesn't at the moment.
Hopefully one day, it will.
This header thing looks a
little bit magic, and it is.
But it's not magic
in the ServiceWorker.
It's magic you can
bring as a developer.
Over in the worker, we're
listening for requests.
And if it's to the API, we
can look for that header.
And if that header's
there, we can just
go straight to the cache
and only from the cache.
And if it's not there, well,
we can get rid of that header
and just go to the
network because we
don't want that header hitting
the network particularly.
It's not useful.
But at the same time,
we can update the cache
with the response we get back.
The important thing
about the code
here is it doesn't
make any assumptions
about the network at all.
It just tries stuff
and sees what happens.
It's reactive, not
predictive because predictive
doesn't work.
Case in point, navigator.onLine.
Aside from having the
worst camel casing
since XMLHttpRequest,
it's useless.
If you have no Wi-Fi
reception and no other data,
navigator.onLine is
going to be false.
Right.
If you have some
Wi-Fi, it will be true.
Even if the router
you're connected to
is ultimately plugged into
some soil, it will be true.
Predictive doesn't
work. navigator.onLine
doesn't know anything
outside the device.
It only knows about
the first hop.
It doesn't know if the
rest of the network
has just soiled itself.
It can't predict
that sort of thing.
Instead, just try
making requests
and react to what happens.
So I've got a couple of
minutes left of the talk.
It's quite short.
But I wanted to throw
together some other API
examples, some stuff that
I haven't covered so far.
If you've got a
ServiceWorker looking
like this-- you're caching
some stuff-- at some point,
you'll want to change that.
You want to change the
URLs that in there,
maybe change the routeing, fix
some bugs, add some new routes,
whatever.
Well, the browser's going
to check for updates
to your ServiceWorker
file, serviceworker.js.
It's going to check for updates
on every page navigation.
You can make this not happen
with HTTP headers if you want.
But by default, every
page navigation.
So just change stuff.
I'm going to change the URLs.
I'm going to use
cache, static-v2.
The fine.
The browser will pick up the
byte differences in the file
and go, oh, this is a new
version of the ServiceWorker,
excellent.
So it's going to file uninstall
for that new ServiceWorker.
But the old one is
going to remain running,
handling requests and
pages that are active,
that are actually using it.
And that's why we create
static-v2 rather than mess
around with static-v1, because
there are pages still using
the old version.
This new worker won't take
over dealing with pages
until the static cache
is ready, because we've
asked it to do that.
But also, it waits for all
pages using the old version
to go away.
And this is important because
it means that you won't end up
with a situation
where you've made
some changes to your
database, but there are still
some pages trying to use the
old model, the old pattern.
And worse, they're
saving stuff that's
not going to be picked
up by the new version.
Of course, you can override
this, like most things.
When you're ready, when
your static cache is ready,
you can call event.replace.
And this is saying,
look, I don't care.
I am ready to go right now.
Kick the other worker out.
I'm going to take over
those pages I mean,
that means you're going to
be taking over pages that
were loaded using old
stuff from the cache.
But if you can deal
with that, that's fine.
You can take over straight away.
Another method can smooth
this transition, reloadAll.
What this is going
to tell-- it's
going to tell the pages that
are currently active to unload.
And when they're all unloaded,
the new worker will step in,
and those pages will reload.
But each page gets the
opportunity to cancel this.
So if in one of the
pages, the user's
halfway through writing
a comment or an email,
it can go, nope, I'm not ready.
I'm going to cancel this.
And I'm going to let
you know when I'm done,
and we can continue upgrading.
You get an event when you're
ready to take over on activate.
And this is the point
where you'll go and delete
the old caches because you
don't need them anymore.
The old worker's gone.
You can do your IDB schema
migrations or whatever.
You can rearrange file
systems and so on.
So this is us
controlling the cache
by changing a list of files.
But you can let users
control the cache themselves
by deferring that to them.
So you might have a page
with a Read Later button.
And when it's clicked,
you can postMessage
to the ServiceWorker,
telling it,
we want to cache the
article with this ID.
And then over in
the ServiceWorker,
you can pick that up
and go, oh, is this
a post request for read later?
Cool, I'm going to
go and find whatever
URLs I need for that article
just using XHR or something.
And when I've got
those, I'm going
to create a new cache
for them, and I'm
going to return
when that's ready.
And then I'm going
to post message
back to the page to say,
yes, that thing is now
available offline.
I mean, this is how
you would do something
like a Read Later button.
It gives you full independent
control of caching and routing.
So this is something that
isn't in the spec yet.
But I just wanted to show that
we were thinking about it.
With your caches,
they're static.
But we want you to be able
to make a cache that updates
in the background.
We don't know the API yet, but
just something like auto update
is true.
And this means that
the browser can
update that cache
in the background,
even when the browser's
not open on the phone.
It can just be
periodically checking
this stuff for updates.
The frequency it
would do this would
depend on how often the
user uses your site, which
is the iOS model, which
works pretty well.
So yeah, all works in
the background services.
It's really nice.
Developing for the web
has huge advantages.
If a thing has a
screen, it's more
and more likely to
have a browser on it.
Most devices now
have a browser on.
When someone goes
down the native path
and develops multiple
versions of the same thing
for different languages, as
a platform, we must ask why
and fix that bug
because it is a bug.
The ServiceWorker is
one of those fixes,
as are many of the
things that are going
to be covered over
the next two days.
ServiceWorker lets you
get content on the screen
seconds faster.
You can use it to ride
smoothly over bumps
and jams in the network.
And it provides the
groundwork for other things,
like background syncing,
alarms, push notifications.
We're looking at putting all of
these things into this model.
And I know know.
You can probably tell that I'm
[INAUDIBLE] speaking about it.
I'm really excited about
this, and we hope you are too.
Thank you very much.
Cheers.
[APPLAUSE]